part of our juneteenth coverage we have
a history-making pilot with us that's
right lieutenant general richard clark
has been superintendent of the u.s air
force academy for nearly two years he is
the first black general appointed to
that prestigious post general clark is
also a highly decorated command pilot
with more than 400 hours of combat
experience a few years ago he commanded
the eighth air force um where the
tuskegee airmen served during world war
ii
general how you doing good morning i'm
great man thank you thank you thank you
for joining us um
as we noted you are the first black
superintendent of the air force academy
um what has it been like because you've
been you've been at this position for
about two years right that's correct
yeah it's been interesting it's been
great though i love being back at my
alma mater
but covid was tough uh we fought through
that imagined being at a service academy
during a global pandemic but it's really
an honor to be there so
and your air force chief of staff and
the vice superintendent are also black
that's true what is it like for you and
the cadets to see that representation in
positions of power and influence well i
think it's a representation really of
the diversity in our armed forces our
air force and we constantly work on that
we think it's important it uh it's a
strategic imperative for us because
if we're going to
have a an armed forces we can't just
build that armed forces from 30 of our
population right we need to be
represented by the entire population if
we're going to defend america we need to
look like america is that a matter of
principle and philosophy or a matter of
actual effectiveness in combat it's a
strategic imperative we if we're going
to be effective we need the power of our
population and diversity isn't
inherently american strength and in the
military we're taught to capitalize on
our strengths so that's one that we have
and we work hard to capitalize on it i
look forward to the day where we don't
have to have uh the first first black
anything i look forward to that day
we're certainly not there yet that's why
we wanted to celebrate you on this
juneteenth do you did you feel or do you
feel stress or pressure on yourself
because you are a first in that position
um i i think at times um i the pressure
for me though is to perform i mean i
have a job to do and i need to do it
well but there's so many people that
have made this opportunity possible for
me i don't want to let them down people
like the tuskegee airmen like you
mentioned nate
i remember this
one event
i was at it was a tuskegee airman
convention and i had showed up in our
chief of staff mark welsh at the time
general mark welsh
he met me there he told me that i was
going to be promoted to three star but
to keep it quiet
and i spent that
that cocktail our time just talking to
these original tuskegee airmen didn't
tell him i was going to be promoted
right but i was just on cloud nine
but then when general welsh he was the
keynote speaker it was when i was a
commander of eighth air force which is
all of our bomber forces yeah um he gave
this great speech about the tuskegee
airmen and then he goes where's rich
clark are you sitting in the audience
where are you rich and he asked me to
come up
and i had no idea what he was going to
do and he brought me up and he's and he
looked out to these original tuskegee
airmen he goes
would you have ever imagined when you
were flying missions in world war ii
that one day
the commander of the bombers that you're
escorting would be a black man yeah and
and those tuskegee airmen it it was so
humbling they started to stand up and
clap and clap and i realized it wasn't
about me
it was about one person who was a part
of their legacy and i it put some uh
honestly some pressure on me to to pay
it forward but we're clapping for you
today and clearly you take the job very
seriously i was reading that when you
first got it covered during covet hit
you spent 28 days
general sir in the dorms with the cadets
i did sleeping on the cots yeah spent 28
days why did you do that
they were going through some tough times
and and i wanted them to know that their
their whole staff all of our
faculty our instructors our coaches that
were all with them and i felt like i was
probably
the best representative of our staff and
uh that we're in this together you have
four priorities for them i do
uh well first to develop leaders of
character and we talk about that all the
time that is most important in any any
realm of life uh was to defeat covet 19.
i think we're in a good place there i
hope i hope we are i hope so um the next
one is to prepare them for future
conflict not not for
next year not for two years from now but
for five or 15 years so that they're
ready for whatever our country might
face and then lastly to really cultivate
a culture of dignity and respect which
is crucial in our armed forces now um
air force academy also trains cadets for
space force we've now given talking
about this your hours hours of
experience in your knowledge
in space force i have to ask because i
feel like a lot of people at home are
wondering
what's with all this talk about ufos are
they real yes is this alien life forum
i can't really see that question i can't
let you leave the set without asking you
that question a lot of americans want to
know if i told you i i'd have
ah well listen i might have to sacrifice
myself for the people they want to know
i wish i knew i'll be honest you you
went outside my my space there did you
go see top gun did you oh i did did you
like it was it unbelievable how
realistic is it well i i thought it was
realistic enough for me to enjoy that
movie oh yeah i thought it was a great
movie yeah that's great yeah cause we
love it we love you talk about great
it's ju it's june 20th today i've heard
from reliable sources this is a really
good day for you oh it's a big day i got
to give a shout out it's my anniversary
my wife amy and i have been married 24
years that's awesome so
uh any chance i get to make some points
with her no doubt i'm taking it yeah
yeah that's great
congratulations to you and amy do you
have a brother just asking for a friend
i do
he he's taken though oh
yeah
i have a son though but he's only 20.
but no thank you
come
[Laughter]
amy i would never i would never
congratulations thank you i'm very happy
for you thank
all right you clark thank you very much
for being here appreciate it